welcome to the across the spoiler vers
podcast hope you guys had a great
Thanksgiving I did I'm thankful once
more to be holding hands across the
internet with my boy Greg from real
rejects always nice to see you Greg how
the hell how's it going how's it going
it's going well man I'm happy to be back
we had one week apart I felt empty
vacant in the soul but I'm happy to be
reunited with you my friend I bet you
felt like mt was going to replace you
you see what I'm saying I was I was
worried that I was like maybe they are
going to do a podcast this week and it's
just going to be Mt on the Pod one day
we should get all three of us it'll be
chaotic it'll be really fun I'll just be
quiet well I'm paying them so I might as
well get money out of them be like yeah
you could come on the Pod but yeah I
hope you guys uh didn't mind missing us
I I think um if you had if we had have
done the episode last week I can pretty
much see us just saying why the Marvel's
did badly again and then talking about
why the Hunger Games did badly but it
has had a emptive Arc and it's actually
done really really well on the second
weekend which we'll talk about in just a
bit um firstly we're going to get into
the box office so going back to last
week the Marvel's completely completely
crashed and burned um and it has beat
morbius as the biggest second weekend
drop of all time for a comic book movie
in the US box office couldn't believe it
and never in my wildest dreams Greg did
I think that an MCU film would hold the
lowest second weekend box office but but
uh yeah they've managed to do it so
77.9% drop from the opening weekend um
with a 65 million us cumulative thing
and uh yeah it doesn't look like it's
going to make anywhere near close to its
money back they're saying optimistically
it's going to do between 200 to 300
million at the box office personally I
don't know um and a couple of months ago
I actually messaged Brandon Davis and I
said Brandon I remember a couple of
months ago you said that that the
Marvels would probably do about $500
million and he got so much crap for it
because especially because the first one
made a billion and uh he just replied
saying something along the lines of a
Thanos meme with um you're not the only
one cursed with knowledge so yeah it's
it's kind of sucks because I I don't
like seeing the MCU do badly I've just
rewatched the Loki finale again and just
seeing the quality they can deliver and
then seeing this you know what the hell
is going on Greg I think it really is
evidence of a damage Brando I look I was
looking it up yesterday CU I just wanted
to know what the because there was two
movies that that I know for sure in the
MCU debuted to bad reviews and mixed
audience reception and that was eternals
and Quantum Mania Quantum Mania still
did had a Phenom even though it
underperformed overall because the word
of mouth was not great on it it still
had a phenomenal opening weekend
eternals which had a real mix bag you
know and not a great uh critical score
either that at least debuted to $70
million opening weekend and domestically
right whereas the Marvel's it just
passed $70 million domestically you know
and normally es especially for a Marvel
film with Thanksgiving weekend when a
lot of times you know the box office on
Thanksgiving weekend can sometimes be
quite generative for for any movie
because families are out and this is and
I imagine that's why they want to
release this in November so you can get
kind of that family box office draw and
to see that it is it hasn't even reached
like a hundred million not even the top
five of the Thanksgiving opening weekend
it's a real clear indicator that there
is all the we had a whole big podcast
about it breaking it down in depth of
the variety of reasons we try to keep
that conversation as nuanced as possible
but to me this is a real test to it you
know like there's a lot of blame going
around for why it did bad like you know
people who really like the movie are
blaming YouTubers or critics or whatever
and I'm like well Quantum Mania and uh
and uh eternals had this had a similar
thing and granted like this is the first
one where it is like all female Le same
time I don't know I feel like I really
do think that the word of mouth on it
isn't as strong as people would probably
hope even for those that like the movie
because the cinema score is still pretty
low or average I don't know about low is
the right word I think it was kind of an
average Cinema score it's sad it is
disheartening and yeah I do miss the
times when Marvel was impenetrable
rolling in money yeah yeah but obviously
we've had other bombs this year yeah
Disney itself's having a really hard
time at the moment so there's just been
a report dropped in the last hour as of
recording this from variety that's has
said not a single Disney film has
grossed $1 billion this year it's the
first time since 2014 not including the
pandemic years of 2020 and 2021 that
Disney hasn't had a billion dollar
release uh during
2019 the studio had hit seven1 billion
releases so it kind of shows you and I
know you're talking about a damaged
brand before I personally think Disney
as a brand are very damaged at the
moment and I think they just annoyed so
many people they've set themselves up to
at the point now where people just want
to see them torn down and they want to
see this big corporation that rules over
everything completely ripped apart for
examples we we've seen with the strikes
and stuff um how Bob Iger was going on
with that you know Disney don't really
have a creative bone in their body at
the moment either that they're kind of
just all sequels and remakes they get a
property milk it dry push it out on
Disney plus you know just get so much
content out there that it it all becomes
watered down it all becomes um kind of
repetitive and it doesn't really feel
like they push the boundaries I remember
a couple years ago there was a d23 and I
was sitting with my mates we were
watching it play out um and there was
and I said to them at the start I bet
there isn't one single property
announced here that's an original Ip
that they've come up with the closest
one they came up with was sneaker which
was based on Cinderella and even that's
that's not really an original Ip we we
might let you get away with it with
snecker but it just I just don't feel
like the credit I don't feel like the
studio is really taking any risks
they're not doing anything creative
they're just doing liveaction remakes
telling stories we've already heard
before you know the Marvels about
getting close to like 50 projects deep
at the moment in a couple years time
we'll hit that Milestone and there's
nothing that really feels like it's
invigorating or special um and wish was
banking a lot on nostalgia that's they
basically pushed the Easter eggs in the
film over the story when promoting it
that's done terribly as well um yeah so
Disney's um wish has opened in third
place with 31.7 million over the
Thanksgiving weekend which is really
really low um Hunger Games speat it they
had a really good second weekend um
they've they've actually you know they
didn't have as good of a first weekend
but they've uh over the weekend they've
crossed $200 million globally after
roing 26.2 million on the second weekend
overseas and it had
98.4 cumulative in the US for that one
um so it's only got a $100 million price
tag according to the reports I look at
the trailer and think it might have cost
more than that they might be downplaying
the budget but from what they put out
there officially the movie is doing
quite well and it does look like it's
going to be another Hunger Games That
People are hungering for but it sounds
like it might be Rachel Ziggler's fault
that it's doing well and I we hate
Rachel's zler now we're angry that she's
doing so well we're going to put red
eyes on her and say flop and burn oh God
I hate her so much um but yeah Greg what
are your thoughts on the way that things
are going with Disney I I I think they
waed too far into politics but I know
there's probably a lot of other factors
and being someone in America you
probably have a bit more bit more of a
nuanced and rational perspective I
definitely don't I think in the US we're
even more black and white about it yeah
I think dis I I really feel like a lot
of it just comes back to Disney Plus in
a lot of ways like yeah we can go into
all the details about the um the
politics and everything and how that has
really created a divide
because the you want to be a little bit
more
all-encompassing and they've kind of
made political stances very clear and
this this is coming from a guy who
identifies uh out here in the states as
liberal and I could still see I could
still sit here and go they really do
they really do off and push stuff though
it is kind of in your face someone who
identifies as liberal like I I see what
the problem is though and I see what
people are are usually talking about
sometimes it does go a little far
reaching um in terms of what people are
hating on I don't feel like the word
woke should be applied to anything with
a female or a person of color in it uh
however they do they do seem to really
um Progressive Pander I would say you
know it's a lot of times it doesn't seem
genuine the way how any brand normally
does they're like huh we can really hone
in and milk this property if we if we
seem like our 1% business that thrives
off of the lower class we we can look
like we're for the people well we know
they're not and I also think too with
Disney plus they the the studios really
did not know how to handle any of this
that happened I'm surprised like
Warner Brothers is such an up and down
experience sometimes they have like
phenomenal hits but if they had like a a
streaming service that was just like we
know that Warner Brothers usually goes
to like HBO right or H or Max whatever
the hell it's called at least out here
right and and uh if there was like a WB
streaming service it was just called
Warner Brother streaming service I
imagine that they would have even more
flops because people would probably just
wait for it and I think just having the
Disney IP have its own streaming
service has made people even for myself
like for wish which I you know seeing
has an A minus Cinema score it could be
a situation kind of like Elemental which
really did not do well initially and
then had legs over time and managed to
do actually like it didn't do old Pixar
numbers but it did Better Than People
expected after its opening weekend maybe
wish will'll have a similar
progression but even for someone like
myself I I'm usually just here going
I'll just wait for it to come out on
Disney plus as a lot of people are and I
think they have really programmed people
to sort of view things in that lens
Disney especially because I think a lot
of people will still end checking out I
feel like Marvel's will be a similar
thing you know the the MCU
they had so many of their properties
when they weren't releasing stuff in the
movie theaters they were releasing all
these shows and then you they were
getting you to think like programming
audiences to to where as opposed to a
movie will come out one weekend you
would have to catch it in theaters you
had to catch the new MCU episode the new
MCU thing once a week for several weeks
on Disney plus so I feel like naturally
people are sort of of drawn to that
people will sometimes defend Disney with
going well Avatar the way of water was a
huge hit but we all know there's a
different exception to that a there's
James Cameron b it was a fox movie that
was already being done and created
before Disney bought Fox so that's not
really a it's like technically a Disney
film but it's not one of those movies
where Disney decided to Greenlight it
and produce it themselves you know like
there's a there's there's a much
different Association
with that so while that is a hit
technically for Disney it's still not
exactly the same thing as when you go
watch a movie where it's so much more
Disney Associated like I don't even
really consider Avatar a Disney property
you know even though it technically is
and so yeah I think that I think
Disney's really it's it's kind of crazy
um because Disney's down all around even
even with like their theme parks and all
that they the how they handled post
pandemic is has been the an extremely
rough experience for them they just
really panicked and I I think it's
really shot them in the foot a lot yeah
and FBS actually put out an article
earlier in the air that we talked about
where they said the cost of streaming
was about 4.6 billion on the industry I
actually think it's done a lot more
damage than that and that the damage
it's done can't be calculated because
it's completely wiped out the physical
media Market I still buy Blu-rays I'm a
bit of a dinosaur but I know most people
will just happily wait for that to drop
on streaming and they even done stuff
where I'm thinking why am I actually
buying these Blu-rays um for example all
the Marvel stuff on um Disney plus it's
IMAX enhanced so you get the IMAX ratio
on that and it's got Dolby Vision as
well whereas when you pick up 4K of it
physically um it doesn't have the iMac
scenes it's all letter boxed and it also
just has hdr10 which is we're getting
into specifics here but Dolby vision is
genuinely seen as being the better
format for it and the better technology
um and I'm kind of thinking like I'm
paying about 25 for these Blu-rays but
I'm already got I've already got a cost
included version of it online I'm just a
bit of a bit of a snob when it comes to
um streaming Greg but it's completely
wiped out the physical media Market
they're actively pushing people towards
Disney plus you're also getting them the
the movies and shows streaming on Disney
plus long before they go to physical
media and they've basically taught Their
audience how to behave and expect their
movies to be leas and if I'm telling you
like oh make sure you give us loads of
money to see this film but it comes out
in for free in three weeks time when a
cost you already pay what are you going
to do if you're not that interested in
it you're just going to wait and they've
basically completely crippled themselves
that $4.6 billion do valuation I think
it's it's way more costly than that
they're no longer selling to third party
cable companies for example when you
know back in the day if you had a a
movie you could sell it off to
television station or you know sell it
to another streaming service like
Netflix but they're putting it all on
Disney plus and it's just this big thing
that's just a sinkhole of money where
they're just losing money for the fact
they've invested so much into this and I
think streaming was incorrectly valued
because
Netflix when it got such high
evaluations it was because it was viewed
as being a tech company and not as a
streaming service and I think you know
Netflix is that Netflix's verticals and
their business model it's nothing like
Disney's sure they both have streaming
services now but Netflix rarely put
things in theaters you know they don't
sell toys and merchandise they don't
have a theme park whereas Disney has all
these different vertical of where their
business is run through and by just
leaning so much into this streaming
service they they've completely crippled
all that and it's cost them so much I
don't think we'll ever know the true
valuation of it but yeah it's clearly
costing them a lot of money well I think
I think what people often forget about
Netflix versus what Disney plus is doing
Disney plus is still so intellectual
property driven where Netflix while
they'll have like a gazillion original
shows that a lot of us will often forget
about when they were having hit
television shows or hit original movies
but primarily hit original shows it was
for the the mold they were breaking the
groundbreaking aspects of it that wasn't
uh you know solely dependent on having
some pre-established IP that people were
aware of you know things like stranger
things or even taking on squid games
things like that that or or mik Mike
Flanigan shows like haunting a hill
house and such it was for the original
Ingenuity that they had there and Disney
plus is mainly going Star Wars Marvel
Star Wars Marvel instead of uh it
relying so much on creativity so I do
agree with one of the if we're looking
at I don't know what is the ultimate
like pot of the slice of the pie chart
of what is the biggest negative impact
that has happened with
Disney I do think though that you know
that conversation that we often hear
with they need to be having uh embracing
creativity like You' you've you often
bring it back to like what Loki season 2
did and I think that within this
disarray of the MCU and it's sad to see
how much Loki season 2 already the
conversation on that has already gone
down because it's been overshadowed by a
lackluster performance of the Marvels
but Loki season 2 was very creative and
it did Embrace a lot of these other
aspects that you don't often see within
the MCU and it really hit home for a lot
of people uh you know even if you liked
it or not there's no denying it that it
really connected with a lot of people a
lot of people found it very original and
I think Disney just relies so much on IP
instead of just telling good stories and
that's what made Netflix origin because
Netflix was cool for the streaming
aspect of oh all these movies and shows
that I already know are here but when
they started having original properties
that were really taking off it wasn't
former IP driven they were making new
IPS and these new IPS are hu like
stranger things is one of the biggest
shows of all time and that was an
original Netflix series and Disney plus
has not done that they haven't done some
origal new IP whereas Netflix has been
able to actually succeed in doing that
even Apple TV is not as huge as any of
those shows but they they have shows
like Ted lasso um SE is sance the one on
there which is the one that's on there
that I don't SE is really good yeah yeah
they have like original shows that
become a big part of the conversation
and Disney plus does not has not
succeeded in that and I think if they
really want their streaming service to
take off they need to not just do
Marvel Star Wars remember that you
you have to do something that is very
different and creative it is not just
former driven and and doing these shows
as well and just making mid TV shows
it's really destroying those big Brands
and IPS as well they're just completely
like killing all the I was thinking
today about phase four and phase five
and I think that if they just you know
finished phase three with far from home
and then come out with like no way home
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness One Division
lowkey season 1 and two um Guardians of
the Galaxy I think if they just had
those five releases everyone would be
like whoa Marvel's doing really really
well but they they kind of killed the
hype with lots of mid uh mid TV shows
which has obviously been affecting the
box office and now we can see the
complete lack of interest in this stuff
um Disney is actually third place in
terms of subscribers when it comes to
streaming services so it's Netflix
number one Amazon is number two they
kind of have it built in no where it's
like if you sign up to Prime you get all
this stuff free but it's still a good
business model and they're clearly you
know making money and giving people
value for money because you get all the
music included you get next day delivery
on Prime you get the TV shows and
they've actually started taking a lot of
risks um with what they're doing richer
I I'd never seen season one until last
week watched all that because I knew the
next season was coming out absolutely
loved it great huh yeah really really
enjoyed it really fun really enjoyed it
and I can see that being a big show I
really can see I see the potential there
you know you've got your first season's
really strong um I haven't seen season
two yet but I have got access to it but
I'm going to check it out um and I think
by season three you know it's going to
get such good word of mouth that there's
going to be people on just completely on
board with it and they're also taking
risks with things like the boys
invincible and I think Amazon are really
putting there a nice thing you know
they've had their failures like the Lord
of the Rings and stuff and where they
spent way too much money but they're
fine in the ground still and I I think
you know Amazon are at least doing what
I would expect a streaming service to be
doing and and really you know putting
money into new IPS and properties and
actors and things that people can get
involved in whereas Disney just seem to
be like what have we got uh Marvel yeah
make a show do we need to read the
scripts do we need to finish the scripts
before we start shooting nah no no one
will care just keep it rolling um and
yeah there's actually been Tao A's kind
of came out and talked about Disney this
week obviously the guy's you know been
yeah he's just been talking talking
recently um but he he spoke about the
Thor movies and he said I had no
interest in doing one of those films but
I was poor and I just had a second child
and I thought you know what this would
be a great opportunity to feed these
children and Thor let's face it it was
probably the least popular franchise I
never read the Thor Comics as a kid that
was the comic I'd pick up and be like uh
and then I did some research on it I was
still baffled by this character
like yeah Tao's kind of just spent the
last year digging his own grave and all
the Goodwill that he had for himself so
everyone look Everyone likes Thor
Ragnarok I think we can all say like
most people think that's a good movie I
really like what we do in the shadows um
Jojo and I like Jojo yeah JoJo rabbit as
well but since then man like the other
week when he was talking he was saying
like his Star Wars movie is going to
piss the fans off I'm just saying like M
you don't understand Star Wars fans you
do you do not tell them that you just
say we're making the exact the exact
thing that you guys want it's George
Lucas's
Vision well so yeah kind of shot himself
in the foot there it's funny looking at
Tao y's uh comments and his attitude
because I I remember a time where when
he was loved and he was respected he had
the same exact kind of cadence he had
the same exact kind of attitude after
his success after witting an Oscar and
then after having um love and thunder
come
out this is he talks exactly the same
way it just translates extremely
different now before it was like ah taqy
he's uh he's ironic you know he's got a
sardonic sense of humor and uh you know
he doesn't he doesn't really show the
sincere side yet now that he has the
success then what he did with love and
thunder everything just sort of reads
now as like smug and condescending it
just doesn't have the same effect and
it's it's strange because if you go back
to what he was like prior you know like
around the time of Ragnarok like this is
the same kind of attitude he would have
interviews but before you're like ah
he's funny he's cool but now it seems
like insensitive and again um smug is
the is the way I I think the turning
point was during that VFX real for love
and thunder when he was making fun of
the VFX artists and I could see I could
just see the tide change then and he
just made a movie that people you know
it was like a phantom menace situation
for me Greg where I was kind of like I
think I did I enjoy that well it was
kind of what and you know came out and
uh yeah I think once people started
really thinking about that film it just
kind of shut it down and yeah just
seeing him being disrespectful to his
workers you know
I think it just rubb people the wrong
way and then to see how he's going on
now about the properties you you kind of
start to think uh if this guy wants to
just come in and mess stuff up is he the
right person for the job if he was doing
a great job in Reinventing the
characters like he did with Ragnarok I
can totally see you know people giving
him leeway but I don't know love and
thunder is just a bit of a mess and what
it does to the characters even from
Ragnarok it's kind of yeah kind of all
over the place and unfortunately we are
seeing a lot of this backlash in terms
of comic book movie interest the long
range box office predictions for Aquaman
and the lost kingdom have came out and
Greg it's not looking good coming in
even lower than the Marvels it's going
to be well this this is long range so
they've still got time to change things
but long range is 32 million to $42
million opening weekend which would it
would be insane because that would mean
this year we've had
two2 billion comic book franchises films
is that have then had a sequel that have
done completely terrible and there were
pointed this out on Twitter though
people are like well technically the
Marvels isn't a sequel to Captain Marvel
but it is it is they're calling it
Captain Marvel 2 in China yeah they're
calling it Captain Marvel 2 in China you
know what I mean mate and I know that's
because stuff like the Marvels in one
division they had some thing where they
weren't allow they were banned over
there for some reason because China just
didn't like Marvel for a couple couple
years is um but and that might be why
but it's still called Captain Marvel 2
technically Captain America Civil War is
Captain America part 3 you know even
even though it's not Captain America 3
it's technically Captain America 3 and
this movie 100% is still a Captain
Marvel 2 uh when you watch the film it
is 100% still a Captain Marvel part two
and this is really bad wasn't Jason
Mamoa just in an interview
saying um like this is my last time I'm
going to be playing
Aquaman it just you go I I don't know
what the intent was there because I
didn't actually watched the interview
but I saw the quote and I saw the way
the quote was going around and when you
see that quote that just registers as as
as at the end of the day most people are
not going to hear that quote and go let
me watch the interview most are going to
hear that quote and go well why the
should I watch this movie you know I
already I already lost like the DCU is
like they already had Shazam of the Gods
tank they already had the flash tank
everyone knows these movies are not
going to matter um by the time um the
Superman movie comes out and this is
just Jason mimoa
going yeah this fun doesn't really
matter either it's your choice if you
want to watch it that's just the way
that that sentiment reads it doesn't
read like like a a swan song for Aquaman
you know it just it just seems like it's
done after this
well James gun famously came out at the
start of the year and was like don't
bother seeing any of this
mate we're we are tying it in we're
tying it in I'm contractually obligated
to say that we're tying it in but uh
yeah don't don't worry about any of the
um so obviously there's been rumors
going I mean there's so many factors
going into this about why the movie's
tracking for Soo um I think the trailers
look all right but obviously you know
Amber herd is one of you know
whether you are on her side or not there
was that massive petition online where
it had like four million signatures to
remove her from the movie say say even I
don't know 75% of them are Bots you've
still got one million people is that is
my math right you've still got one
million people on that signing up to to
try and get her removed from the movies
so that's a big chunk of the audience
whether they actually stick to their
word and boycot it is another thing
entirely but you know it drums up a lot
of bad publicity for it um it's also
connected to this universe where you
know the flash hasn't done well Shazam
hasn't done well Blue Beetle hasn't done
well and they've clearly being like it's
on life support and they're about to
pull the plug like right yeah we're just
gonna have all the family come in to say
they good buys and then we're pulling
the plug on the dceu so that's another
reason um there's also rumors that Jason
Mamo is going to be lowo and James ju
you know he he got paraded about during
the week and he actually released a
statement I'm I'm not going to read out
the whole thing and but he was basically
saying about all the love and care that
he put into this film didn't mention
Amber herd at all um talked about how it
was a story about Arthur being a father
skirted around looking after his family
um but said it was very much a Brother's
Tale the latest trailer doesn't contain
Amber herd that I think they are trying
to downplay that I don't think it'll
have a massive difference you know on
the box office if they don't mention her
at all I think people have already made
up their minds and that they're not
going to see this either way um and it's
just a disas really it's got me thinking
I think this in the Marvels has kind of
shown that there was a time when these
Studios could just crap out side
characters but I think at the moment the
the movie's just if it's got a C or a
dless
character people just aren't interested
in it if it's not part of a grander
story and that's what Marvel have really
fumbled the ball with on phase four and
five we don't feel like there's that
real direction that they're heading in
it all kind of seems like they're just
just randomly throwing out these
projects that aren't necessarily
connected and it is affecting people's
interest in this story you know they're
not they've said Kang's going to be the
big bad but whenever you watch a project
didn't see him getting killed off you're
kind of like is he though and then you
hear the rumors about stuff and you know
directors leaving projects des and
Daniel keton stepped away from Kang
Dynasty the Writ has being fired and
yeah I think I think just at the moment
when you know something is connected to
a shared Universe it has that shared
Universe has to be special because
otherwise you're just going to see a
standalone movie which maybe you know
eight years ago the these movies would
have been groundbreaking in fresh but
Greg I can't get moved for superhero
content you know what I mean I turn
around there's superhero content there
look I've got W of comic i m TV is
playing superhero crap all the time yeah
it needs to be special Greg and a lot of
people have seen a lot of this stuff and
really got to we really got to sell it
as than you well the thing though is
often times people will get upset at
well we want more Standalone film and of
course we do we we want Standalone films
that do feel special you know uh the the
spider-verse movies I don't watch them
to see how they connect to Sony's
Spider-Man films it is exciting to see
like the the amount of Spider-Man that
are in there and everything uh but I
those are like its own thing still at
the end of the day like those
spiderverse films are pretty much their
own thing while they the second one does
step into the Venom world for like a
little bit it's more like just a fun
moment than it is setting up the grander
side of the Sony Spider-Man universe or
something like that right like I I don't
really get that impression and at the
same
time what one thing I've heard go around
with Marvel's
is is like it's in a rush to there's two
sides I've heard of it some people say
like you don't need to see this movie
movie other people have said it's only
in a rush to get to the post credit
scenes for the rest of the universe so
I've heard two very Contra contradicting
sides one sounds like well I need to
watch it to get to the post credit scene
and the and the ending scene but do you
though Greg because we already know the
X-Men are coming we know the X-Men are
coming like I don't need another X-Men
post credit scene I know Deadpool 3's
coming right I know Wolverine's in it
right right that's what I'm excited for
my main point I'm getting go see the
Marvels to get it my main point I'm
getting at is
this this idea
that when it comes to Connected
universes like yeah you need this the
individual films to feel great but it's
also not the audience's fault why they
expect the connected universes it's not
the audience's fault Marvel vem trained
us the all audiences to expect that and
to be on the lookout for it and for that
to be the thing to get excited about
they they programmed that into audiences
with the start of phase one that's what
made the comic book um that's what made
the comic book property Skyrocket was
the connectivity and while I am there I
I do it is possible to have a gray
opinion about this is to go yeah you
want those individual films to still be
great like Iron Man one is still a great
film um but the connectivity side of it
you do when when people are often
complaining like well you just wait to
see where the Multiverse Saga goes when
a lot of people are sitting by with
their arms folded going like I don't
really see where this is going I don't
really see what the connection really is
uh I I want I want to get a better sense
of the direction the reason why
audiences really want that is because
Marvel trained us for that they they
trained not just the film Geeks here but
just general audiences to expect that
and to and to um kind of hang on that
wire for things so in a lot of ways it
is their fault why people get upset
about the lack of connectivity or the
connectivity not being very clear for
people if that makes sense that's all I
was trying to say that's all I was
trying to yeah and I think I'm gonna
slag everyone off listening this podcast
Greg but I think everyone in the world
is lazy I think everyone in the world's
lazy and clip that out of context and
just put it as everyone in the world's
lazy but let me explain what I mean for
the longer context listeners Greg sure I
think when you put out so much content
people just think well I'm not catching
up to it now I had my fill with endgame
you know I'll I'll I'll dip I'll dip in
here and there and watch a no way home
but there's no way I'm watching seven
different Disney Plus shows to get
caught up to speed on this but something
that really doesn't matter that much I
think most people will be fine going
into Deadpool 3 not having seen any of
these Disney Plus shows or having seen
the captain you know the Marvels post
most cred scene there'll be people going
into that thinking oh Monica Rambo I've
never seen her before she must be a new
character in from the X-Men universe or
something um so yeah I really don't feel
like you know that I I feel I do feel
there's too much homework and a lot of
it's you know a churn to get through it
really is you're just kind of like
sitting there going okay like we we
cover it weekly so it's not as bad
because it's our job to do it but when
you you haven't been keeping up to it
week to week and you look at it like
there's so many shows that are like
suits I really want to get caught up on
then I look at it and it's like well
this is is going to take at least four
weeks of my life it's going to be a
full-time job watching this and I think
I'll just leave it I'll just leave it
there and I think a lot of people are
like that with the Marvel Studios stuff
at the moment where it's like uh it's
more of a job do I care about these
characters you know they're not the big
names that they're launching at the
moment you know Spider-Man of course is
but lots of CN D lists that that they're
you know they're not worth spending all
this money on to go see and I think I
think Marvel is doing the right thing in
the future which is that their you know
One release next year but even then I
just see like Agatha House of harness
I've heard very bad things about Eko I
was I did come around on the trailer and
think maybe those things are wrong but
for the fact they dropping it all on one
day during January um yeah we we'll have
to see but uh yeah I haven't heard I
just haven't heard good things about it
and we we'll see what happen happens
next year but I just think that Marvel
really need to be careful at the moment
and to me they actually feel like
they're sort of in a similar position to
what DC were at the start of the Year
where they know they have a lot of stuff
that's already been filmed it's already
in the can they have to release it they
know it's going to devalue the brand and
it's just kind of a case of well get
through it and uh hope that you know we
we have enough good projects in between
that people are interest and I think
that's why next year it's going to be
very very Deadpool focused I think it's
so to that oh God you need the break
they need to you need the break
releasing the Marvels and Loki on the
same day that was so stupid and I talked
about this on Twitter saying they didn't
even give Loki half a day of good
headlines to be like the mcu's back and
it was already back with the Marvel's
bombing on you know box office wise the
bad Rotten Tomato score and people I
called them lazy I'm also going to call
them they love a bit of drama as well
and they love a bit of you know things
going badly what was that green gobling
quote Greg the people love a hero they
love they love a hero loads but what
they love more than a hero is to see a
hero fall and that's kind of what stuff
is with the MCU right now we love
watching it go up but when it comes
crashing down and all the drama channels
you know all the people who wanted to
see Disney fail for years they just
jumped on the Marvels doing badly
they're not making Loki videos um
they're not making Loki headlines the
articles are just all based around what
the what how badly the Marvels stayed
when we could have had like some focus
on Loki for at least half a day they
couldn't even give us that and yeah they
just they just shut themselves in the
foot so I think we're going into
2024 get get Eko out the way you know
the AGA trailer looks all right the Echo
trailer looks all right but we'll see
how it goes but Deadpool 3 that trailer
is is going to break the internet I
think and yeah just seeing Hugh Jackman
the boy carried the entire X-Men
franchise on his back he's here to carry
the MCU as well and I'm very excited to
see my man in h in all his glory what I
really hope they don't do with Deadpool
though what I really hope they don't do
what MCU doesn't do is because because
they could really take advantage of the
conversation with Deadpool 3 I feel like
Deadpool 3 will probably has a good
chance of being a billion dollar hit so
there they get another billion dollar it
has a good chance of being that and and
then if they they they just let the
conversation write that and if it does
open up all these possibilities for the
MCU the way how we've heard that it
could potentially do let the theory
because a big part of of the
conversation is the theories for what
could happen that's what made Wanda
Vision such a such a huge show Dr
Strange as well yeah exactly let the
people Garfield and and if they let
people simmer in
positivity really let them marinate in
that
positivity and on top of that too let
them marinate in anticipation for the
next project so I think not making sure
they don't just go Deadpool 3 was huge
we're back let's start releasing a bunch
of now you know let's let's green
light like six movies next year I really
hope they learn their lesson and go hey
maybe we shouldn't release so much stuff
and I know that they've been saying
that's the
plan however I do get a little concerned
that if they have one great huge
phenomenal film that they will suddenly
go all right well we're back let's just
start dumping all over again when
they could really use Deadpool 3 to
change the entire conversation around
the MCU in every way that's my hope and
just stop giving us Marvel all the time
like we need to have that anticipation
build which we're not going to have um
but yeah just in general Greg over
Thanksgiving I watched the Thanksgiving
movie and I was like what is is this
what it's like in America but really
enjoyed that um but I also saw Bobby
Greg text you saying I was watching it
enjoyed it I did enjoy it I must say the
Ben Shapiro influence didn't didn't get
to me and I really enjoy enjoyed it yeah
I really enjoyed it it was good it was
nice funny fun film um yeah me and my
wife sat and watched that and yeah had a
good time with it did your wife like
glad that yeah my well my wife seen it
before she she soon as she seen that it
was available because we went to Center
parks with the kids and yeah it was
available there so I just thought yeah
time to bite the bullet and just watch
it and then was sitting there smok face
I hate when they start saying stuff like
women you can be you want to be I'm like
oh number one thing that annoys me in
the world H but yeah loved it cracked it
just cracking Smiles it was it was good
yeah so if you if you you were a rage
and sexist like I am um then definitely
check it out and it might change your
mind on equality and just seeing that
all people are just people just me and
you and should be a quality um so I'll
probably get cancelled for saying that
we should have equality but there's
actually been a lot of cancellations
going on this week um I'm kind of glad
that we weren't covering things last
week because the scream franchise it's
been getting killed out there Greg and
obviously this is a very um nuanced
topic I don't want to Wade in with the
jokes uh and it's it's just it's so sad
what's happening out in the world and I
think you know just seeing just what's
going on I mean it's devastating it
really really is and and Melissa Barrera
is someone that you know talked about
this and yeah she she got fired from
scream for for putting out um statements
that they viewed as being anti-semitic
um I will say I haven't seen everything
that she said but everything that I saw
she said I I didn't think it was you
know it said she was downplaying
genocide and stuff and I yeah I
personally didn't see it and obviously
online there was a hell of a lot of
backlash over it um she actually put out
a statement herself saying that she she
won't um she basically said silence is
not an option for her um and I think
Hollywood in general you know that
there's so much like anger around the
screen franchise now the next day it was
announced that General TGA will not be
returning to the role now it is
important to say that the reports have
since clarified that it's because of
scheduling conflicts with Wednesday and
that it was nothing to do with that I
kind of feel like that's pios been Greg
i'm put my conspiracy theory hat on for
a second I'll tell you why because the
script hasn't been written uh there's
not like it's not in production so how
and they they fired the main actress
they've had to rewrite things from the
ground up so how can how can there be
scheduling conflicts when there's not a
schedule for that film yeah um you would
just say like well we'll wait until she
finishes Wednesday then we'll get the
ball rolling but either way you know
she's now resigned um probably ghost
face is going to be announced next um
but what was your take on the whole
situation oh wow well I mean I did a
live stream and it was like the
predominant part of our live stream like
it was a really really really long live
stream and then even caught her
statement that was released the end so
trying to condense down these thoughts
into just a few minutes it's going to be
very interesting because I know this is
a very sensitive subject
around I I think you know I think the
way we should do it be respectful is
just kind of talk about the situation
itself in Hollywood rather than you know
what's going on because it is it's yeah
it's just it's it's not something to be
made light of or even bring you know we
go down that route and yeah it's it's
devastating um and I think just you know
we're a movie podcast and just trying to
stick to the movie point of view stuff
is it's probably the best way to go
about it but I I think the easiest way
to summarize it because naturally a
little bit of the the actual political
side of it will come in a because
because that's what led to her getting
fired what was that and when you really
like try to boil down what she was
talking
about whether or not you actually
full-heartedly agree whether or not you
agree with her or not she her her intent
that she was really asking for is peace
that's what she was really asking for is
peace and the part that
rub me the wrong way because I saw what
like Susan sendan said that got heard a
drop by CAA and reading that I'm like o
yeah that's a little I see how that
comes across a little that comes across
pretty ugly in the what she actually
said and yes there's more to the
conversation and yada y y but I can
understand that one little that one
sentence that was going around of what
she said I'm like o that does not sound
good when you look at what Melissa
Barrera was
saying she was was she at the end of the
day that's what she was asking for you
know and I think what's important to
understand is
that she has made it clear
herself that like criticizing government
for example like just to take it out of
the way sometimes Paul will tell me
things of what he's critical about with
uh you know UK government stuff right
but that doesn't mean he's like he hates
the UK or some like that and he's a
he's a UK citizen same thing here in
America like of course there's things
politically that happen in with American
government politics that were I I can be
critical about but that doesn't mean I
hate being an American and or I'm
anti-American or something like that and
likewise with
her yes you can be critical of Israeli
government stuff but that doesn't mean
that she is attacking people's religious
beliefs or their Creed or something like
that you know and same thing
with
again watching sort of what I say
because at the end of the day I'm not
the most educated person in here the
more I learn I've been constant and I've
said I've had these conversations with
Paul in private about stuff uh the more
I learn the more I realize I don't know
as much as I would like to know so it's
just a constant learning game of going
like damn I there's so much more I don't
know there's so much more I don't know
and when you think about what she was
saying with saying she is like Pro
Palestine she's not saying she's Pro
Hamas in their actions though what she
was going after was the fact that a lot
of people in Palestine are children and
you're seeing what's happening with them
and the part that really just rubbed me
the wrong way and I think what's rubbed
a lot of people the wrong way and what
you initially brought up was like spy
glass saying like they don't condone
they don't condone
anti-Semitism and um false things about
genocide and whatever well I'm like well
no she's not she's not saying she's
she's not she hasn't said anything
anti-semitic and I I know that some
people can be very if if they if they're
really involved in the conversation and
and they can feel like sensitive towards
things and I understand we can have our
interpretations on the receiving end of
stuff however when you really break down
what she's saying I I personally do not
believe what she was saying was
anti-semitic my personal belief just
from reading it I did not think it was
anti-semitic from talking with other
people who are more well-informed than I
am and who can get very emotional
getting involved in the conversations
about these things I I I just don't
think that she I think what's unfair
about it too is how she she was like go
when we are like what was getting
brought up a lot was people like Amy
Schumer and Noah schnap who had the
complete antithesis side of what they
were saying a completely opposing point
of view and the main thing that Melissa
Barrera uh which I think first garnered
her a lot of attention for this was she
was actually criticizing Western media
for I think I think what she was coming
down to is Western media censoring what
is happening in Palestine and not giving
enough coverage to that whereas like on
social media I see a lot of that but not
actual like television media social
media I see a lot about the Palestine
side but not television and that's I
think she was really being critical of
and I think she was trying to shine a
light more on that than anything else so
I think I just don't think she should
have been fired for it personally I feel
like a conversation could have been had
and maybe there was and we don't know
about One um but again yeah I'm I I'm
trying to summarize everything all at
once I don't know if that was really
clear at the same time like I said I'm
not the most difficult to talk about and
yeah I think I genuinely do think that
you came out respectfully and that's how
I'm trying to do it as well uh yeah it
just breaks my heart when I see this
stuff happening um and just some of the
videos and and that it really has tore
me up um I'll try and keep things you
know centralized because we're trying to
do a movie podcast but that there has I
think Hollywood's issue in general over
the last couple of years is that they've
waited far too far into politics um Co
was another thing where they got way too
involved in that um the elections always
get involved in the Ukrainian Russian
war which has kind of just been brushed
on the rug now that's like it's still
going on and it's just been completely
out of the the media cycle and obviously
what's going on now and they they do
then they clearly pick aide as well they
clearly clearly pick aide and I think
it's it's always going to divide the
audience because you know it's very much
it's right and left is very much 5050
you know that they have maybe one gets
the majority but it's never to the point
where it's like 6040 it's always
normally if one has the majority it's
like 52% or something and I've seen so
many politicians even being fired for
calling for a ceasefire and I think you
know Hollywood need to just remember
that they're here to entertain and not
way too far into this stuff and that if
they do it's going to cost them in in
some ways because they're going to
alienate people who support certain
courses but yeah as they've benefited of
aligning themselves with I identity
politics and personal beliefs so if they
Market a movie or their product with
something that you identify as or see
yourself as you're going to associate
that product or brand with your personal
self and that's why they do it it's
because they believe that if people have
a personal attachment to something
they're going to be more likely to buy
into it and more likely to support it
and they have started doing this but
it's also going to it's also getting the
point now where they're dealing with
really serious issues and I know even us
just talking about it on the podcast is
going to alienate some people um
unfortunately it's the way that the
world is and we are covering these
stories um but it just hasn't it's not
scream 7even is going to do really
really gonna have to like they've got an
uphill battle trying to sort this stuff
out now um and they've actually returned
to Patrick Dempsey and Neeve Campbell
and asked for them to to re to return to
the franchise and this is all coming off
the back of what happened with NE
Campbell earlier in the air where she
said she asked for a certain price to be
paid they said she's not worth that she
is the face of that franchise and that
disrespect is incredible I kind of
likened it to I hope she's like David
Brent in the office when he gets fired
and you you see him out on the road and
he's in the hotel and he's going how
much you got because it's going to cost
you and I hope she's like that and but
they've really shut themselves in the
foot with this and it's just caused it's
caused a complete crisis and
unfortunately Hollywood waited far too
far into this stuff now where they're
firing people for having what are
basically opinions and you know they
they can lambas them and say they're
calling for the for genocide and stuff
and downplaying it but if you really
read into
it I think anyone with any Common Sense
who you know might not be invested in a
certain side who's just coming down the
middle of it they'll see that and I I
just don't think it was the right way to
handle it and I think the Optics on it
have been absolutely terrible and yeah
it's just taking them to get involved
almost in the conflict themselves to the
point where you know that're they're not
they're they're clearly supporting a
side they're clearly supporting a side
and I I just don't feel like it's it's
what they should be doing and how they
should be positioning themselves because
it's such a complex conflict that's been
going on for decades you know we
obviously have our own certain views on
it that we're going to keep out of the
podcast like but I I think you know that
the it's way more nuanced and for every
argument you have there's going to be a
counterargument and it's just just when
it's when it's life and death and you're
talking about making Scream
movies it's just I don't know what
you're doing yeah and maybe there were
enough people because you know the there
are people who did um on the receiving
end uh whether Jewish or not Jewish who
who did find their interpretation of I
think there was one specific post that
went out where the interpretation was
like oh this this is anti-Semitic to me
like the way that it was
interpreted uh that way and again like
I'm just here saying well my like what I
saw it didn't register that way to me so
maybe for those who felt that way
because it's this is such a sensitive
subject of what she's talking about of
what we're talking about we're we're
trying to treat this with as much
sensitivity as possible because you know
Decades of of something that has been
really taking the spotlight lately um
you can't just summarize it and we're
not going to we're not having an ongoing
conversation with people in the comments
about it right now where they can
respond to us and then we're like well
actually let me elaborate here or
something let's talk about our different
point of views we're not doing that
right now and I I do that's why I'm
saying like I think like a conversation
could it doesn't it just didn't seem to
me like spy glass had a conversation
with her about hey we I want to talk to
you about what you meant by these poster
that's what should be is there some
Middle Ground here where we can be like
do you mind do do you mind like maybe
not this is where I get the subject gets
even trickier because I understand Free
Speech sort of debate yeah yeah I don't
think they should have just fired her
out she literally posted it and was
fired within a couple of hours and I
think that's so drastic it's not even
really get you know giving her the
chance to and and sure she' done she'
done a number of posts but I don't know
I think you have to kind of approach
your employees almost as if everything's
kind of not a black and white issue and
at least allow them to explain
themselves and yeah yeah I mean and free
speech is is um protecting you against
like uh government punishment you know
like like she's not going to she could
say whatever she wants so like spy glass
there are within their right to fire her
they they are true true like Melissa
Barrera is not gonna you know go to
prison for anything she's saying or to
go to go to trial or anything like that
you know what I mean so like she it's
it's nothing against her free speech uh
it is that the conversation does get
bigger when you do think about well
there's other people who are celebrities
and faces of properties and stuff who
who will put out a completely different
opinion than her and there's doesn't
seem to be repercussions for them and it
it does start to open up that ground of
what about isms and also what is
fair uh and all this stuff and to me
this just doesn't seem I feel like the
Nuance got lost and if anything with spy
glasses done which is kind of like the
ironic part is because I didn't know
about anything Melissa Barrera was
saying until she got fired right and
then it did become a deep dive on like
there have been people who have been
posting like countless things there's
one thread in particular Point like
everything she's been posting and then
like it's just deep do through all of it
and the ironic part about what spy glass
has done is
by firing her they have given more
attention to what Melissa Barrera has
wanted to be out there even more so like
wait why was she fired and for people
who probably aren't even involved in the
conversation of what goes on in Israel
in Palestine now they're getting more of
that perspective and point of view and
hearing more of the people supporting uh
Melissa barrera's point of views as well
so if anything they've in a strange way
like it's they've harmed her career
because this is something where as a as
a as a non-white actress it's already
hard enough to get work and now she has
and she while she is a great act like I
didn't really love her in Scream five
but I thought she was amazing in Scream
Six uh this this this can make it harder
for her to get work
naturally and at the same time when it
comes to her political messaging she she
just got more attention for it and so in
a weird ironic way now the message is
out there even louder than
before definitely defense of irony to it
sense of
irony yeah I mean that that's the issue
that you run when you you wait into
politics you kind of you know you get
pulled to a certain side and that's it
you know they've aligned themselves with
the opposite to what she's saying so
that they're pretty much stuck in that
position and you know you don't the
thing is it's an unfolding situation as
well and we don't know what's coming
around the corner and that's why I do
feel like it's best for a lot of people
to just almost you know like there was a
great tweet I seen once that was
basically saying all social media is
like that Dave Chappelle skit where they
go to jaw rule on 911 to ask his opinion
except everyone on social media is jaw
rule like you don't have to give your
opinion on all this stuff mate and yeah
you like you can totally it's totally
fine to stay silent if you you're still
unsure about things and I think waiting
into these politics is kind of always
going to cause issues but onto some more
positive News Greg um I've missed out
I'm wearing the T-shirt I wore on
episode but I forgot to shout them out
but this is adopt my block it's a
charity on the Streets of San Jose that
basically my my mate Dan he run it and I
give him some uh I just donated to it
because he was running it I donated a
couple of times and but what they do is
just take dogs off the street care for
them find them homes it's a brilliant
charity adopt my block um yeah so
donated to them didn't WR anything back
but he was like oh I'll send you out
some stuff so he sent me a T-shirt and a
hoodie and I was like I'll wear that on
the podcast give you a shout out but uh
I forgot to shout out them out that time
Greg because we were so deep in the news
so I'm making up for this this time guys
um so yeah adop my block make sure you
check them out you know they do great
things for dogs just dogs are the best
the look after them um so yeah lovely
lovely little Charity and onto some
lovely Legacy casting Greg Superman
Legacy I don't know if you've seen the
photos of David horn sweat floating
around but the man is looking jacked he
L he literally looks like Henry caval
with a beard um but yeah the the full
cast of James gun Superman Legacy is
starting to build up you've obviously
got David Corin sweat as Superman Rachel
BRZ nahan as lowest Lane and it just
announced Nicholas Holt as Lex Luther
Lex Luther I'm actually I was a bit kind
of funny on this when I first seen it
the first five minutes but I thought
about it I thought who's my favorite
Luther it's bloody Michael Rosen and
he's sort of yeah he can sort of be in
the same vein as that I think casting
him is the same age interestingly
Nicholas Hol actually went into audition
for Superman he auditioned for Batman
you know he auditioned for Superman
didn't get either of them but he's got
this and I actually think you know it's
quite a good mirror take on it you know
having someone who could play Not only
Superman but also Lex Luther and I think
what they can really do well is have the
ego thing with this which is where
basically Lex Luther has built himself
to Perfection he's a genius he's a
multi-billionaire he's got these massive
businesses he sees himself as someone
who should be loaded in the same way as
Superman and if they even have you know
they hav someone who could have played
Superman but all he he just doesn't have
those superhuman abilities and that chip
in his ego is just what drives him
insane I think it's I do think it's
quite good casting what they've done
they go that route they might just have
him doing fart jokes because it's a
James no James G we say
what I think I think um Nicholas Holt
absolutely deserves a a huge film where
his face can be seen he's a very
talented actor man I mean he was you if
you kind of look at his filmography
of like what has he done recently uh he
he like I know he but he was also in
like the
menu um of course we know him as beast
in the uh prequel X-Men series he's been
in Mad Max the guy can do a he he played
token the guy can do like a variety of
genre very well eloquently he's got a
handle on uh on any kind of genre you
you throw the guy into he can pretty
much do and uh I think just even when
you look at the the cross
between sort of what he's like in the
but he's display it's like part of Lex
Luther is he's he's such a just one
aspect of his many he is he's a genius
and and he's also very rich and he's got
that Elegance about him right so if you
can have that level of Rich elegant
genius just looking at his work in just
some of those movies that I listed off
right there you can see sort of an
amalgamation of all that and he's also
vness so and he's and he's done that you
know even in menu and stuff so he can do
all these types of characters and I
think with the wide variety of work
because most of the public kind of knows
him from just a few roles uh but if you
do look through the guys like IMDb at
least and you see what lead characters
he's done and even if you go like his
Rotten Tomatoes I'm sure a lot of those
movies or and shows have really good uh
critical audience reception that people
have been drawn to his work the there's
something about Nicholas Holt where I
wouldn't have thought of him to be the
guy cast for it but when I when I heard
it I was like oh no that that does make
a lot of sense when you think about
everything the guy has
done it seems like a no-brainer like he
could definitely pull it off and I'm
excited for it man I think he absolutely
deserves to have a big role like this I
think I think he's going to be good I
think he can kind of switch between
being Pleasant and happy but also
commanding as well I think it it's a
really interesting take to have Superman
sort of go up against his mirror and
have that embodied in Lex Lether now
we've also had some other casting in
that Ana Taylor Joy is apparently going
to be playing a a Herald of galatis in
the upcoming Fantastic 4 film this isn't
confirmed been lots of more fantastic
for casting news to hit you with it's a
different actor every week it's playing
Musical shares with them um but there
were rumors that Silver Surfer was going
to be Silver Surf her and it was going
to be a woman so now people have heard
that you know an Tay Joy is playing one
of his Heralds most famous galatis
Herald is of course Silver Surfer so
people put the two together and assume
that it's going to be her Greg how you
feeling about this I'll I'll tell you
how I'm a bit I'm a bit and I'll tell
you why it's not because I hate women I
promise you guys not because I hate
women just
wait I'm too sad of it man and I'm not
trying to play Both Sides here I'm just
naturally can say things from both sides
guys I'm naturally two sides one part of
he's like I don't really give a if
it's if Silver Surfer is a female the
other side of it is why make Silver
Surfer a female exactly because it just
seems like it'll provoke people like
what would be the purpose of of doing I
can't I I don't see like a strong story
choice for making Silver Surfer a woman
at the same time I don't really care if
Silver Surfers woman like I'm not going
to be part of that camp that's really
upset uh about it like I I sort of
associate Silver Surfer as like like a
cool dude in silver with no genitals
just riding around a surfboard and it's
kind of a stoic personality you know and
and like they they gender swapped a
Ancient One and uh I think till the
Swinton absolutely knocked it out of the
park but I I was kind of at the same
mind mindset I was like I don't really
care and then I think but I but the
thing is ancient one is nowhere near as
famous of an iconography you know famous
imagery like even if you don't know
Silver Surfer in comics or whatever I'm
pretty confident you've seen Silver
Surfer like everyone has probably seen
some image of Silver Surfer so they know
Silver
Surfer uh it it just seems like to me
that I can't I don't I don't know what
the and maybe they have something up
their sleeve other than we just wanted
to make silver surf for a woman I'm of
two minds one part he's like I don't
really care the other part of me is like
going well are they going to give me a
reason to care of why Silver Surfers of
woman so when I say I'm I'm on two sides
of it I basically go and my personal
feeling at first is I'm not that
affected by it that my other feeling is
going but but why wh why why would they
do that like I become puzzled by the the
idea of making silver surf for a woman
because
it it seems like if you're going to
finally bring Silver Surfer into the MCU
why not just do what we all know Silver
Surfer to be you know and uh yeah that's
just kind of where I'm at about it is
like I don't I don't really see what the
justification would be other than we we
just wanted to change up the gender just
cause you know and I think it sounds
like you don't want to see women playing
Silver Surfer Greg by the sounds of it
I'll tell you why I'm not that com well
well I'm not it it's just what Marvel
have done with villains recently go the
god butcher they had Christian Bale in
the role I thought oh my God this has
the potential to be one of the best
movie movie villains of all time
completely messed it up and look what
they've done to K guys's sort of a joke
now Dar Ben wasn't really a big Dar Ben
fan I'm going to be honest with you but
just the way they handle villains in all
honesty I think Marvel have kind of
almost went back to that phase one and
two villain sort of thing that they had
where they just they they got big act
like Christian Bel toy that they got
such a big actor in fumbled the ball
with it didn't do the villain right and
I just worried that they're gonna get
you know Ana Taylor Joy is going to
become another villain that gets wasted
in what is you know an iconic role and
should be something massive um and I
think you know I think I do think Silver
Surfer remain a villain though no I
think silver Surfer is someone who would
stick around so they do have more leeway
there but I think they'd really have to
just I I just hope Marvel realized that
they they're messing stuff up with the
villains in these films and that
Christian Bale stuff mate that should
have been the last straw you had
Christian Bale as go the god butcher
that should have been that should have
been the next level thing but they
didn't do it they messed it up and just
in there's even talks of Mads mikkelson
being brought back um but playing Dr
Doom and I was like what do they mean
brought back and they like yeah he was a
villain Doctor Strange I was like ohly
crap he was if anyone finds out I didn't
know that my Channel's going to get
defunked like completely defunded and
taken down but yeah I forgot for a
second because that's how unmemorable
that they hit that character was and
what they did with they cilus K they
completely you know wasted that um I
think Loi and Thanos and vulture I would
say those are like the three villains
where I'd say they really hand those
guys
well konger yeah killmonger um the high
evolutionary I really liked as
well yeah but they can often fumble the
ball and seeing I just don't want to see
another good actor wasted in this part
um and we've actually just had some
breaking news come in Greg breaking
breaking exclusive exclusive um so
Michael Waldren is now GNA be writing
both K Dynasty and Secret Wars and
that's been officially announced by dead
line yeah so Jeff lovess is we've heard
for ages that he's been fired um but
yeah kind of you know the other week I
was a bit worried that Kang was going to
get replaced um we were thinking he
should just be recast sounds like
they're just they're going all in on
Kang and uh I hope that they start
really doing some stuff with it um so
yeah he's Michael walren obviously
worked on Loki he did Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness which I like I
know a lot of people don't but yeah um
excited to see what he does with it yeah
I think uh I think we'll see what
happens yeah I don't know I I'm not that
ex I don't know why it's not really
doing anything for me I I feel like my
think the risk I'm just so like this
Avengers King Dynasty news has been so
up and down yeah like you yeah I think
the risk with having him do right two
films as well is that if one sucks
you've still got to go ahead with the
second one it's like oh crap me I mean
we heard of all the the changes going on
with Multiverse of Madness and it sounds
like they just rewrote the script so
many times I think Elizabeth olon was
just she stopped reading them because
they were getting so many different ones
um so hopefully they keep him on track
but uh yeah speaking of keeping on track
we've had Dave filon now officially
promoted to become the chief creative
officer of Lucas film so he's going to
be working directly with Kathleen
Kennedy to oversee All Star Wars
projects going forward now he's pretty
much in the Kevin fgy role of Star Wars
I think it's welld deserved I think that
in his hands Star Wars is in the best
hands possible I know not Everyone likes
everything that he does but I would say
on the whole he respects the brand he
worked closely with George
Lucas he's I don't feel like he he's
trying to ruin things and just yeah I
feel I feel genuinely that he is
probably the best person for the job and
I think that Star Wars is in a good
place with him leading it yeah man like
Star Wars especially they need someone
who the thing about any intellectual
property thing in Star Wars now
is you can't it's not just about keeping
your current fans happy it's also about
you know being able to gather new fans
and you need but now Star Wars is also
in the position where they have to
consistently seemingly redeem themselves
with people who have given up on Star
Wars you know people who were Big Star
Wars fans who hate what Star Wars has
become Under the Disney rulership and
you and I think one thing about filon is
like well I can sometimes be there too
and be like H sometimes his scripts are
a little bit wonky in their dialogue or
whatever it's Star Wars the overall the
mythology and the the way he Embraces uh
the building out and expansion of the
world and the overall exploration and
just understanding of the
characters I feel like is the most in
sync with George Lucas for very obvious
reasons and I think the key to
having to being able to help attract new
fans and helps and and make current fans
happy and at the same time rebound with
some fans who have been really upset
with Disney Star Wars I do think filon
is ultimately your best bet and being
able to do all three uh the new fans one
is actually kind of the hardest one for
me with Fon because so a lot of times
the in the camp that he works
in like like Ahsoka is actually a
perfect example of that of a lot of
people being like oh man I I was kind of
like felt a little bit left out because
there's so much lore and myth ology from
all this other that I do not I
don't know about so I had a there's some
stuff I just couldn't keep up with MCU
problem yeah yeah and so that would be
the thing with filon where I think he
would need to see how he can redirect a
little bit where people don't feel that
way because while there have been a lot
of people who did not see rebels in
Clone Wars who were still able to really
enjoy Ahsoka uh there were definitely
still some people a good amount I would
say that that fell off after the first
couple of episodes because they couldn't
they were like I don't know who these
people are why I should care you know
and and and a lot of that care came back
to well if you saw Rebels you would care
you know and and and I think that's
where he has to really kind of come like
combat with himself a little bit is
making sure he can still attract a new
audience and not just keep the Clone
Wars and Rebels fans
happy yeah that is true yeah he does
kind of lean into his own St quite a lot
um and you know will that be a good move
I I I feel like yeah I do feel like
filon because I feel with Falon though
he's got a good understanding of the
prequels and why fans like them and a
good understanding of the original
trilogy he's not he's also not really
roped into the sequels either like he's
not you don't think of Dave filon and
think of the sequels you think of the
earlier like clone wars and Rebels and
and stuff like that and Mandalorian and
things that people are more favorite
towards you know like Ahsoka as much I
don't really feel like there's any you
know that there are some people who
don't like it on the internet um but I
don't feel like it's it's a hated
property you know what I mean I don't
feel like there's that anger that there
is towards the Last Jedi in Rise of
Skywalker and he's not really connected
to that stuff either so I feel like it's
it's a positive move I do want to see
Star Wars do well and I would love it if
we just had a a Star Wars project come
out that was universally loved and there
was no will it ever happen I doubt it
but I've just kicked my camera out but
yeah yeah so will it ever happen I
really don't know um but they'll
probably show I've got a letter there
with my address and I'm probably just
docked myself um but yeah we'll we'll
we'll see but Dave Fon I'm rooting for
you guy you've done a lot of good work
you know you haven't you've done like
he's like a lot of people when you put
out that much content he's done a couple
of bad things here and there but I would
say on the whole you know 95% of the
time maybe even higher the guy makes
good stories and at worst he makes mid
and I would say there's very few mid
stories but hell of a lot of good ones I
love the way he directs though you know
like his episode of Mandalorian and the
ones he directed in Ahsoka I think he's
a phenomenal director uh like sometimes
I feel like his directing is better than
his his actual exe I always think his
outlines are great like like the
whatever the the whatever he wants to
tell is great um it is sometimes I can
be a little bit in conflict with overall
execution but I think his voice in the
writing sings the most when he's
actually directing it as well where you
just get the full filon vision so I I
really like the way he directs and I'm
excited for his
movie and what I liked about ahoka the
most out of anything in it is that it
took Star Wars into a new direction that
hasn't gone since the prequels I really
feel like a lot of the Disney stuff was
kind of
just trying to cash in on Nostalgia you
know as much as I like Andor and that
character Rog one was very much like the
Death Star plans who kind of build the
movie around that and I love that movie
but it was very much rooted in like
trying to recapture the feelings of the
original trilogy the sequel Trilogy
hell solo you know what I mean
it was they were all kind of bagging on
that but the fact that Dave filon took
us to a new universe sure he brought
back thron but you know he's someone who
kind of not necessarily had the exposure
that the other people had and he came
from the expanded law and yeah the night
sisters and stuff like that he kind I
know they were in the Clone Wars and
Fallen order and stuff like that but it
felt like he was really evolving Star
Wars from Beyond what it's been in the
past and giving us new things and a new
Direction instead of just being like
let's cash in on everything that's come
before and just do do the same story 75
different times or if we don't do it
we'll do it for a bit and then
completely ruin everything and try and
subvert expectations yeah very excited
to see what he does with it I'm hopeful
that he's going to bring stars back I'm
hopeful Marvel can return Michael walren
we'll see we'll see Greg hates Silver
Surfer I hate per
usual I'm gonna clip that out of context
and just put it on there but I can say
that I I don't hate women Greg because I
watched Barbie this this week you see
what I'm saying you conquer I'm not one
of those men who refuse to watch Barbie
yeah thank you guys um and thank you for
all your support again I know there's
ladies out there who watch this we love
you just as much as the guys might even
love you a little bit more if you know
what I'm saying um but don't tell the
guys we said that because they'll burn
down the entire Channel and say we've
gone woke but it's good having you guys
as always I hope you don't mind us
taking the week out we probably took too
long of a break and now no one cares
about our opinions um yeah we'll try try
to have a good good conversation there
Greg I hope you've enjoyed it as well
have you got any final words where the
hell you going get back in your chair of
a I need to run to the door close
us out Paul okay okay guys well Greg's
got to run to the door the Hitman has
finally arrived he's knocking on that
and yeah I'll see you guys next week
across the spoiler verse we're on all
good podcast Services Spotify Amazon
Apple you want it on YouTube we' got
that as well love you guys missed you
the last week you are the best take care